[Musique]
c'est c'est forcément quelqu'un qui
gueulent tête et que tellement qui
galèrent buy fait que des conneries il
fait et tout le monde
un mec qui met des capus 6 mars à
travers 6 à des racailles and
anniversaire et toi tu es dans ces cas
là tu vas être dégoûté un dérivé
fulbright jeu tout ils volent des petits
objets personnels non même en cas il ya
une connotation voilà quoi mais qui
valide tap
il fait son business quoi c'est une
carrière à la poste il ya quand même
démarche
quand même de marquer son territoire de
marcher la tête haute de provoquer un
peu les gens le système
c'est devenu plus un adjectif genre
voient comme je t'ai dis tu achètes un
truc genre tu dis ouais je vais acheter
une bécane et toitures vie avec le
nouveau modèle doté une grosse carotte
tu conduis anker oualata bianca
oui
sauvageons lascars galeria wesh wesh les
substantifs ne manquent pas pour les
qualifier ils ont longtemps effrayer le
bourgeois mais aujourd'hui l'image des
cailleras est en train de changer
il ya une espèce de fascination pour la
callas qui dépasse d'ailleurs la
banlieue parce que tu regardes tu vas en
province ou même chez les jeunes est ce
qu'on appelle des petits bourgeois ils
sont fascinés par les cailleras main à
tout le monde ce tchèque où on parlait
ce match entre eux on est branché mon
frère au cinéma à la télé sur internet
dans la pub la musique ou la mode
ils font désormais partie de la culture
populaire de notre pays
bonjour
fondateur du coup
bosch mais qui cocotte
ouais on n'attrape pas les mouches avec
du vinaigre punk il ya les métalleux il
ya les rastas et il ya les caméras
comment sont ils passés du ghetto au
salon des français de a comme accents
avait comme vannes voici l'abécédaire de
la culture keira l'histoire d'une
mutation aujourd'hui une séquence
particulièrement très importante nous
sommes sans conséquence innovations des
mythos des comptes inquiète à partir d
une manière de parler bien particulière
un phrasé appuyer la caillera
s'entendent au loin et se reconnaît à
l'oreille un accent développer à l'ombre
des tours de nos banlieues
un accent énervé
qui dit colère dit forcément sur ces
français eddy phrase est un petit peu
plus bas depuis un petit peu plus sur
les consonnes tu vois le tout en tout
cas c'est une attitude et après comme on
reste toujours entre nous restons
toujours quand ils sortent de l'autre
côté du périph
c'est du mal à enlever l'accent me et il
faut parler vite et fort pour se faire
entendre il faut savoir qu'en milieu
populaire
il ya une certaine promiscuité on
partage sa chambre on partage la
télévision on partage la rue on partage
tout donc quand vous avez trois quatre
personnes qui tchatche en même temps au
bout d'un moment où pouvait plus prendre
la parole vous n'existez plus
socialement respect qui vont dire oui
ils prennent à l'accent arabe
je trouve pas je trouve que c'est plus
proche du gitan où il ya un débit assez
certain pas forcément d'articulation
parisiens marseillais lyonnais l'accent
keira s'adapte aussi aux terroirs de
france quartier émard bull ça vous c'est
un quart du coup on va rentrer et tu
verras ce tacle ou la boîte à chaumont
frères véracité seulement être un sport
qu'il a et c'est madame tant et plus
tu vois il ya plus en europe quoi tient
que par la personne ne sait plus se
parle comme ça anna foot s'est passé -
c'est plus renfermé axa dit du sud - tu
vois c'est piot a cessé ces deux accents
différents qu'on qui sont qui sont
qu'ils sont sympas parce que quand tu es
une caillera du sud c'est ça fait ça
fait moins flipper quand tu parles
[Musique]
mon début trois modes pourrait dire
pendant longtemps à de rares exceptions
près pour le cinéma français la banlieue
était une terre inconnue
scénariste et réalisateur parisien
franchit c'est rarement le périph pour
nourrir leurs scripts en 2012 franck
gastambide né et élevé à melun dans le
77 signe la première comédie 100% keira
succès aussi massive qu'inattendue
un million de spectateurs et film le
plus rentable de 2012 quand on a lu les
cailleras tout d'un coup on avait
l'impression de 2,2 de faire un voyage
dans un pays qu'on connaissait pas
beaucoup
ce qui nous intéresse vite ce qui nous a
vite intéressé pas renoncer c est ce que
ce voyage qu'on nous propose dans ce
pays qui existe réellement est un voyage
qui est sincère
[Musique]
tourné à la maison hamelin un film avec
de vrais morceaux de keira dedans
ferme ta gueule tu fermes ta gueule
ferme ta gueule ferme ta gueule toi
aussi
non mais j'avoue ramzy sein des
meilleurs rôles de vrai mais qui bête et
méchant et il y en a plein des comme ça
c'est à dire son rôle à la roma il est
bête en plus je vois ce que les mecs les
plus méchants beaulieu il a beaucoup ils
sont maîtres les cailleras ou les
aventures de losers sympathique filmé
avec tendresse dans leur quotidien pas
franchement glamour
[Musique]
une approche quasi naturaliste très loin
des productions choc présentant la
banlieue comme l'enfer sur terre
depuis quand les mecs ils vont à 2 80
avec des radars et des hélicoptères ils
vont à 2,4 euros
mais c'est pas vrai ça ils ont la
voiture mais jamais roll it et donc
c'est un c'est de la mito ça disent
n'importe quoi
moi j'ai jamais fait de go fast jamais
braqué deux banques j'ai fait que des
petites conneries et ma vie c'est
surtout le sait surtout d'être sur un
banc avec mes potes à maré et elle se
dire on fait quoi soir les gars bas
viens on va manger un grec à
saint-michel et tu prends un rer
tu fais une heure de rer pour aller
manger un grec et puis quand et après on
fait quoi vous hip hop et on rentre et
hop on repart chez moi je sais pas si un
film qui s'appelle les racailles en
verlan
ça aurait pu exister il ya quelques
années en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est
que le succès de ce film a étonné
beaucoup de monde et nous les premiers
c'est à dire qu'on avait l'impression
que cet humour banlieue contre est dans
les cailleras n'allait touchés que les
concernés c'est-à-dire le public de
banlieue
c'est à dire nos potes quoi avec
intouchable omar sy l'enfant de trappes
devient une star nationale en incarnant
une gentille racaille qui fument des
pétards et roulent sans permis mais aime
son prochain
résultat 19 millions d'entrées un césar
et une projection à l'elysée avec
nicolas sarkozy
prix essayez-vous maintenant avec
intouchable ça a changé mais avant c'est
un peu genre fouet mais a pas de thème
loire puis joue pas bien que les noirs
en général j'ai entendu tout comme ça
c'est pas de suite en train de faire le
parano balancer des trucs qu'on te dis
ouais les noirs jouent par josh hill
machin truc c'est toujours compliqué
maintenant c'est ok mais faut que ce
soit voir si le jeune des cités devient
alors l'ingrédient miracle pour épicer
certaines comédies trop franchouillarde
thomas n'gijol téléporter aux anti otan
de l' esclavage
omar sy à contre emploi en flic de
l'autre côté du périph et même
bernadette lafont en mamie dealeuse de
shit coachée par les lascars de sa cité
sans oublier joey star icône caillera
qui multiplie aujourd'hui les rôles
parfois les plus surprenants 15 ans tu
deviens dossard tout faire tourner un
film mais tu seras un homosexuel était
emballé tout forme une pelle un mec
mais avant même que tu as terminé ta
fraise et aurait égorgé aujourd'hui te
dis ouais bah si tu tues mais combien
pour en arriver là il a fallu que le
ciel les oiseaux et ta mère révèle
jamais le cinéma il y a quinze ans que
jean françois richet réalise un film
coup de poing dans sa cité de seine et
marne au bord de l'explosion
[Musique]
et que la haine films fondateurs de la
culture keira révèle à la france le
malaise de ses banlieues
il y a déjà 20 ans
ils ont grandi en ayant vu la haine et
en se disant qu' il était possible de
faire un grand film de cinéma avec des
mecs de banlieue et maintenant on rentre
dans une heure ou deux ou trois fois par
an on aura un cinéma qui ou viendra de
là où on regardera ce ce territoire là
avec un peu plus de bienveillance et un
peu moins de clichés que que c'est la
nasa late le hip hop c'est la bande son
des cailleras et voici son hymne
choqué si si
marcher dessus
pour le faire cependant les maires de
commun où elle jouait ce cousin 24
accueil pour les calanques où je vais
pas mon genre un morceau qui a été fait
de manière spontanée
c'est un cri du coeur c'est on s'est dit
on va représenter tous les gens qui sont
pas représentés tous les racheter et
c'est comme ça qui est né ce morceau
morceau phare de la mafia k 1 fry
collectif de rappeurs du 9 4 le clip
pousse au maximum tous les curseurs du
style caillera pitbull motocross dents
en or
le tout emballé par gavras et chapiron
le duo très branché de kourtrajmé
triomphe immédiat 6 millions de vues sur
le net mais que nous aurons j'écoutais
faites nous confiance
on veut des tranches de vie on va
prendre ce qui se passe vraiment chez
vous quoi ça s'est vraiment fait comme
on dit à large
c'est en même temps je pense que c'est
c'est la première fois qu'on fume et les
quartiers comme ça sans qu'on voit
entrer une caméra et qu'on se dise bon
ces mecs là ils vont nous filmer mais
pour nous [ __ ] toi dix ans plus tard
pour ce a fait école
pas une cité digne de ce nom sans son
groupe et grâce au numérique les vidéos
aumède sont tournés au pied des tours
comme ici à bondy 50 qui vola chômage
préfère son banc ak 47 pour danser plus
rentrer leurs sites divers dérapé à la
cuisine la mare nippon des ovnis
l'amérique c'est pourri qu'on ne lui est
pas là je suis en zigzag les rois de la
nec sont les braises déco fort que nous
observons dans la boîte ya pas assez de
miroirs van niekerk année c'est tu
retrouves ce côté des durs des quartiers
ce côté brut c'est parce qu'elle avait
lé brut dans ces quartiers là quelques
paramètres du 16e il va être là il a
quoi raconter je te dis 16e c'est un
cliché en mai 18e du 7e tu vois il a
quoi raconter d'intérêt sans sa petite
vie rangée où il va faire du poney
personnes à la duchère le quartier le
plus chaud de lyon on est très loin du
poney club et lamson santos rappeur et
producteur travaille à la maison
un studio d'enregistrement installé dans
une cave de deux mètres carrés pour les
déménagements c'est l'auto production en
mode keira le système d appliquer ou hip
hop
donc moi je mets mon petit logiciel et
jean pierre mangé achrafieh quoi ça fait
ça en somme ce on n'a pas droit
normalement se faire des trucs comme ça
c'est sûr locale un micro une feuille
giscos faire entendre et pour la
diffusion internet a remplacé les
maisons de disques
m
hier a lancé m
moi
[Musique]
mais chacun
cette espèce de revendication de tongs
eto'o qui parfois peut être très mal
interprété ou tu vas te dire mais les
gars c'est ce que vous avez envie de
montrer de l'endroit où vous vivez à
montrer plutôt les parcs et les enfants
qui jouent ensemble
rem et un moment ta fierté tu va la
chercher au site ça parce que c'est de
là d'où tu viens
c'est ça qui fait que c'est difficile
pour toi alors tu valeurs revendiquées
parfois de manière excessive et puis à
un moment où ça tu échappes et où le
petit blindée du xvième où dix huitième
ou même des branches et de boîtes
parisiennes vont danser comme des fous
sur des morceaux de rohff sur des
morceaux de booba sur des morceaux de
rim'k qui a priori ne les concerne pas
du tout et raconte des choses qui ne
sont pas du tout en corrélation avec ce
qu'ils vivent et pourtant ils vont
bouger la tête et ils vont faire comme
ça avec leurs mèches qui bouge et c'est
ça un phénomène en fait un phénomène
mais booba longtemps incarnation du
rappeur ghetto aujourd'hui invité sur le
plateau de la star ac
une vraie cash machine un million
d'albums vendus des concerts géants à
guichets fermés
et à 38 ans une semi retraite dorée sous
le soleil de floride
il ya vraiment un paradoxe entre d'un
côté des cailleras qui sont en réalité
très conformiste et pourtant il incarne
la rébellion les adolescentes des
classes moyennes sont les premiers à
acheter
cette pseudo rebellion puisqu'ils sont
dans un monde quasiment 100 rebelles et
que le pseudo caïd du collège apparaît
comme un rebelle terrorise un peu ses
parents la casquette la musique le rap
tout ça en général les parents en ont
horreur donc c'est utilisé comme comme
mark hurd comme un moyen de rupture
générationnelle
la preuve que nous on a raison on va
dire les mêmes les pubs ça les influence
est démarqué fond des bois font des
semis hip hop je sais pas si tu vois non
mais michael est le sucre avec une
affreuse valmont gueule cela aux frères
[Musique]
bien voir ici maastricht
g km
[Musique]
baptisé grecque mais inventé par un turc
à berlin dans les années 70 le kebab a
depuis conquis le monde entier un
produit hautement addictif moi je m'en
suis tellement gavés je crois que c'est
j'ai dû manger l'équivalent de dix
moutons dans ma vie avec le nombre de
kebab que j'ai mangé c'est pas cher déjà
je roule pas sur l'or
c'est rapide a pas le temps jamais le
temps c'est bon c'est de la viande on a
été nommé à la viande
on la voit tourner toute la journée on
est là on dit et tu reviens à la
maigritude voix des purées la dope pas
ça doit pas être la viande la plus
propre du monde codjia mais nous a
tellement fait du bien ouais un kebab
c'est quand même l'assurance de plus
avoir faim pour en acheter un à 1 5 ou 1
2 on peut en acheter deux pour un mais
c'est sur un plateau sur un papier et on
peut piocher comme ça on encore quand
même entre un sandwich et manger à la
main on peut piocher la viande de danse
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que c'est
quand même un truc ou visual aussi
alternative route à l'impérialisme du
hamburger le kebab et est profilé pour
séduire toutes les communautés 250
millions de kebabs sont consommées
chaque année en france
à petit
il restait aux grecs à se faire une
place sur les meilleures tables de
france et les dernières digues sont en
train de céder le kebab devient hype
dans son restaurant gastronomique proche
de la place vendôme
thierry marx revisite le kebab façon top
chef un chef qui connaît bien son sujet
thierry marx a grandi dans une hlm de
champigny sur marne
et des années que je défends l'idée ta
cuisine de rue comme une cuisine
légitime épanouissante parce qu'elle a
permis aussi à des gens de s'installer
de créer leur propre entreprise
il ya aussi ce histoire l'histoire
économique autour autour du greffe et
puis il y avait un clin d'oeil d'abord
par rapport à l'extraction social d'où
je viens de dire ben weyts entre la rue
a du talent contre la rue fait de la
qualité
quand il ya une économie de la qualité
ça peut fonctionner aussi
la route du kebab sas et c'est important
oignons curcuma et cette viande cuite
euros si tout est dit si vous fermez les
yeux vous êtes dans un kebab ça c'est
important
c'est un univers le kebab avec ses
odeurs avec ses bruits avec ses
l'environnement sacré message en fait
plus de ces flammes dimanche mais
j'aimerais marin pour est capable avec
frites et suppléments main tendue mais
thierry bien voir la stopper
il nous faut des kebabs de mon spécial
qu'on a 300 ha
c'est dommage ça c'est dommage parce que
le client de l'a 310 les partis ce matin
la reine d'angleterre
c'est pourquoi tu dis ça nous
aujourd'hui si t'as pas de débat
peut-être que donne
entre le crocodile et les cailleras
c'est je t'aime moi non plus vénérés par
la jeunesse des cités la marque a
longtemps très mal vécu le culte dont
elle était l'objet
je me sens à l'aise là dedans je me
reconnais c'est la grande marque du
remake du werther du bitume du quartier
on a commencé à voir ça sur les anciens
les plus âgées qui ont on a vite compris
que c'est un luxe de porter cette marque
or créé par le tennisman rené lacoste
dans les années 30
l'emblème du sport de l'élite n'avait
pas franchement vocation à billets la
banlieue attend personnes jouent au
tennis à part quand il ya roland garros
les gens ils jouent un mois au tennis
aft contre une chaufferie ou contre un
mur il donne des rôles y soient fournis
tout ils sont là ils ont commencé les
shorts votre chien ne sont pas contents
quand on achète ça mais il faut qu'ils
sachent que nous concevons 10,6 et du
300 400 euros pour le magasin tout passe
un petit vieux ils achètent un polo une
chemise temps en temps tiacoh pardon
merci bien a+
c'est drôle de se rendre compte que
cette marque multimillionnaire été
complètement impuissante face à tous ces
mecs de banlieue qui à un moment ont
décidé que cette marque elle était bien
pour eux même si cette marque ne voulez
pas deux le déclic il y a vingt ans les
rappeurs d'arsenic pour look total
lacoste popularise le crocodile vert
depuis le survêt et la casquette lacoste
font partie du dressing de tout caillera
qui se respecte il va être dégoûté parce
qu'ils n'ont tué sa marque a franchement
toutes les petites caméras qui mettait
du lacoste mais qui ne vais regarder
famille lacoste est dégoûté la place
mais c'est vrai qu'on plus si j'ai vu un
reportage où justement il essayer de
relancer la marque de manière à ce
qu'elle touche une autre une autre
partie de la société quoi
pour contrer loupé à des cailleras sur
la marque la cause des sites dans les
années 2000 d'élargir sa ligne pour
gagner sur tous les tableaux
le chic et le streetwear ça veut dire
qu'ils ont des modèles magnifique mais
qui sont pas faits pour la banlieue de
qualité supérieure design et par des
vrais designer et ils ont des modèles
grossier le mec je crois il en cure de
désintox ils envoient des mails mais que
des gros cocody comme ça horrible on
peut dire que c'est des dragons et voilà
comment ils se sont dit voilà on va
calmer la banlieue ce qui est marrant
c'est que ça donnait une sorte de street
crédibilité à lacoste qui maintenant
revient à la mode croyable résultat la
marque véhicule aujourd'hui une image
très éloignés du central de roland
garros rajeunie et métissée et le
crocodile ne s'est jamais aussi bien
portée un milliard et demi de chiffre
d'affaires l'an dernier et une
croissance à deux chiffres
les cailleras c'est plus fort que toi
il veuille ou non la coste a été créée
par des tennismans pour les ter c'est
tout je suis désolé rené verdon à la
basse unis dell qui parlaient entre eux
ont peut être compris par les autorités
c'était ça le truc de base de l'argot
c'est de ne pas être compris d'avoir un
langage que les autres ne comprennent
pas boloss cousin tertaire coyotes steak
gros la langue des cailleras et des plus
fleuris et des plus imagé aussi un
métalangage qui se renouvellent en
permanence chaque mot est pesé et
attention aux erreurs de syntaxe ziva ok
j'ai dit ça est trouve moi un mec j'ai
32 ans j'ai jamais entendu le terme chez
toi si t'es urbain il te tend les bras
dans les quartiers patron rupins ici les
frères ne se bat plus pour du pain le
rêve américain gratuit
in arsène lupin tu penses bien en fait
les choeurs faible sur bar le ter père
le terrain
[Musique]
il ya une radicalité une efficacité dont
le langage caillera qui fait que
personne peut rester intentions des mots
qui collent au rap leçons de la rue un
langage autant qu'une musique bâti sur
des punchline des textes choc des mots
qui cognent
cannois calme a fait pas qui je rendais
visite à défaire comme nicky cuisine
calmement sa régie milk sa mère dans ses
chairs égide du d'espoir sport perd ce
soir tu vas faire 120 go 2 go de gaudiès
cailloux comme ray tous les seuls à y
fait des monnaies dans l'underground des
studios d'enregistrement des sites et là
tout le monde va commencer à dire sans
âme genre capi dame il reste un verre de
coca
pourquoi tu pars il sert envers le guen
s'en tape à partager
[Musique]
aussitôt créer aussitôt diffusé ces
expressions sont vite reprise par les
poids lourds de l'industrie musicale
comme booba rohff
[Musique]
mais comme rohff que j'aime beaucoup a
lancé une expression qui s'appelle en
mode etc en raflant sans mode
aujourd'hui tu allumes ta télé tu
regardes faire une petite vite à des
émissions qui s'appelle en mode
[Musique]
vas-y ta mère ont pris la mer au casino
j'ai envie de me faire greffer le nez de
cléopâtre mans je le kiffe
c'est génial non sens économique souvent
je regarde les émissions télé et qui ou
voilà on va dire 2 des émissions de
jeunes des moins de 25 des trentenaires
et cetera les oulémas des magazines de
culture et tout mais qui parle comme nom
parle quoi un langage cru différencie t
il ce revient à dire da par n'importe
qui consécration il y a dix ans la
prestigieuse nrf analyse les textes de
booba est chelou fait son apparition
dans l'édition 2014 du robert le langage
keira a même son dictionnaire le petit
livre de la tchatche le vocabulaire
keira expliquée aux nuls
retour à l'envoyeur le lexique de la
tchatche passé au banc d'essai de la
cité
[Musique]
après je pense trop une très chic
fraîcheur à une corde se trouve une
fraîcheur est bon on ne dit pas ça on
use it chez une tumeur direct qui me
fait mal à la tête
futur bébé de 2 2 samedi
ouais c'est ça venir de très rapidement
et vite c'est un des deux gratte et
l'amitié
la salle est petit les petits veulent
trop reste avec nous et saint charles
polonais colonel fall à l'achat mais ça
va du spectacle avant de dire quoi les
gommes et de 0,2 pour l'os est ce qu'il
y est elles sont huit mètres coup sûr
ils ont promis par région qui les fait
au tuba ou la région paris de nos
colonnes c'est sûr qu'il y ait pas parce
qu'il ya que nous serons là-bas à lui
ont déjà et le dit pas et hier à 79,83
touaoula dinars au lieu qu'on aimerait
bien sûr c'est bien ça évolue mais la
langue française et les volumes c'est
génial c'est super n'ont jamais compris
où était le problème comme moi quand
j'étais petit j'avais appris lynch emmen
lu chez bmc le langage des bouchers de
rungis et après on a fait après on a vu
le verlan après et puis rappelez vous
que coluche
dans leur reportage d'une fois je vois à
la télé c'est pas des moutons noirs les
mecs qui faisait peur de l'époque lé
fait que leurs blousons là et il arrive
en mobylette essais ils avaient des mots
et les gonzesses tu m'offres une gueuse
à je te donne une pinios 1 je te fais un
clope
bon ce n'est pas la limite du langage
keira c'est qu'il n'est pas toujours
compris par tout le monde a bondi dans
le 9 3 la mission locale pour l'emploi
des jeunes propose des formations pour
aider les demandeurs d'emploi à accéder
au marché du travail
deux mots que la jeunesse aimerait bien
ajouter à son vocabulaire
cette dure à gauche voilà se tenir droit
et avec élégance sur une chaise rouge et
noir ont regardé la personne en face
accepter les conseils et les critiques
la critique positive ou émotions
négatives
ok on passe aux points suivants
s'exprimer de manière compréhensible ou
bien par les personnes qui parlent trop
vite
auo confrontant faut marquer enfin
s'exprimer avec un langage soutenu
georges frêche
comment ont été reçus wesh wesh quand tu
rentres dans le bureau au jour monsieur
n'à qu'à donc tu vas attendre à recevoir
d'accord tu attendras vraiment adapté un
peu à la personne qui est en face de toi
je ne pourrais pas parler comme d'hab
comme d'habitude avec vous je sais pas
c'est comme ça c'est quelqu'un que je
connais bien il sait comment je suis
c'est du tout de suite c'est même s'il
m'aime pas moi c'est comme ça c'est je
sais pas je parle normalement ça va plus
ça va toucher tout comme tu vas me dire
quoi un étranger un espagnol je mets en
france il n' en espagne et pendant huit
ans dix ans c'est normal et par
l'espagnol après quand même réussi à
apprendre le français mais quand il est
chez lui avec ses parents si tout de
suite c'est pas passer tout de suite
c'est il va même pas dire bonjour maman
que l'instance et aulaqui en espagne
donc c'est un vin nous tournons les
simples à préparer
on a grandi avec cette langue là est
arrivée à l'école on devient un peu bien
par les courants on se faisait reprendre
par des profs
donc après terre on essaie de faire la
part des choses tu vois
c'est ma flamme et poison
[Musique]
la caillera a une façon bien à elle
d'aborder les filles entre laval et le
compliment garçons et filles ont du mal
à se comprendre et la drague reste un
sport périlleux
c'est défini il faut un peu de tout ou
surtout un peu de rien ça va toujours
essayé de draguer en faisant une vanne
par exemple là je suis avec un pantalon
déchiré vont dire tu t'es fait attaquer
par un r c'est parce que tu avais envie
d'entendre tu vois donc oui c'est
maladroit mais en même temps ça les rend
salir en charmant tu vois il ya une
petite comme sa timidité qui se cache
derrière tout ça et c'est une maladresse
qui les rends moi je les trouve charmant
en fait mais bon je vais pas dire trop
dire ça parce que tous les jours tu t'es
fait attaquer par intègre ou quoi vous
allez dormir ce soir y ait une rave
party au sol ans rejoint la banque oit
non je demandé s'ils avaient une rive
haut niveau mais le ciel comme ça me
donne l'adresse ça
j'ai bégayé et quand on est dans des
groupes de dix mecs étaient évidemment
pas en train d'essayer de chercher une
meuf là au fond de toi tu le sais tu as
juste beaucoup plus envie de te marrer
avec tes potes c'est moi en ex saint
jacques chirac elle s'est moquée
c'est moi qui ai réussi la boule c'est
difficile de plaire aux dana tout en
étant dans l'état d'esprit du choix
cette époque j'avais des dieux on est on
est des choses voilà jamais dire que tu
es amoureux quand un certain das un
petit peu la honte
dès que tu es un petit peu romantique on
traite de canard donc voilà donc il faut
pas que tu fais tes potes monde
augmentera tes potes qui était un canard
mais un peu comme pour mieux te pêcheurs
la meuf quand tu es quand elle a vécu un
match fait de savoir quand même tu vois
hockey lch et j'ai tapé un pas trop
draguer les filles des cités parce que
c'est souvent la soeur 2 alors ils ont
passé c'est tchatche 200 potes et 50
ennemis et tu pourras pas ces trois
censeurs deux de tes potes donc
forcément il ya une pudeur il ya il ya
un truc il y a un truc qui propres au
quartier c'est normal et ce truc là
ouais ça écrit me tue de frustration ou
à dire ah les filles en général les
évitent de sortir avec un mec de leur
quartier par exemple les meufs de 9,4 je
dis pas toutes les meufs du 9,4 avons
préféré avoir un mec dont 92 ou dans le
93 et les meufs du 9-3 relève d'une de
9,2 pour peut-être préféré avoir un mec
du 9,4 du 19e où tu vois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais t'inquiète pas pour eux ils
arrivent toujours à ça termine avec une
annonce et des fois même des boeufs bout
tu dis mais comment tu avais l d'initiés
page découle est très touchant il m'a
parlé de vous in mesbah j'ai trouvé ça
tellement original et puis attention à
des nanas qui kiffent sortir avec des
cars ans c'est le côté du bar n'a envie
de calme si saint baudile veut carrément
messari à la voix c'est justement plus
autonome un an maintenant j'ai pas mal
réfléchi et je pensais qu'on pourrait on
parler tranquillement
donc je voulais être imputé à jean rède
jamais toi tu es bon tu bouges pas moi
qui va coller bon en fait lorsqu'on est
suffisamment pour qu'ils me proposent un
peu un troll continuera
[Musique]
ce film scarface il parle aux gens parce
que c'est un mec qui vient d'immigration
cubaine c'est un mec qui est dans
l'illicite c'est un mec qui réussit
c'est un mec qui se marrait que la plus
belle mère du fils c'est un mec a de
l'argent comme obama samedi peu
l'exemple c'est mais qui partagent rien
qu'avec avec ses couilles tu arrives à
l'écart et hoppop seule chose dans ce
monde qu'il étonne les sortes
c'est le manche est et queens scarface
c'est l'épopée sanglante d'un petit
immigrés cubains se hissant à la force
du calibre au sommet du trafic de
cocaïne à miami
sorti en 1983 le film de brian de palma
est devenu au fil du temps une oeuvre
mythique le point de référence ultime de
la culture qu'ailleurs
j'ai des mains prêtes pour la raison
dans la merde des mecs sont faites pour
autant de noms mais étudie avec l'accent
en plus de cogner tu t'enflammes qui on
s'est tous pris pour scarface mais cette
réplique elle veut tout dire elle veut
tout dire montre l'assurance du mec
elle montre sa soif de réussite elle
montre son ambition déjà
[Musique]
dans des quartiers où le trafic de
drogue constitue parfois un moyen de
subsistance voir d'ascension sociale
la figure de tony montanna trafiquants
aussi intraitable que charismatique
avait tout pour plaire et dealer de
drogue séguelon que vous êtes quoi dans
un quartier de banlieue a vendu du shit
ou de l'aco et balades d'un seul court
par les miracles du cinéma tout devient
super glamour
les filles sont magnifiques les boîtes
de nuit sont délirantes c'est miami
c'est le voilà il fait même beau il fait
chaud colette to tatou taille d'un seul
coup ils sont en hélicoptère au lieu des
temps r19 enfin je veux dire donc d'un
seul coup pas forcément le type fayçal
sublime lui-même
oui mais voilà depuis niveau violence la
réalité a largement dépassé la fiction
finir les plantes coq de but et passeur
et à faire ça criblé de balles saab
amour aux vicois 3 trente ans après sa
naissance le mythe a du plomb dans l
aile
et
rien de positif dans su je regarde y'a
pas une cenne genre c'est un peu un peu
tu as envie d'être sensible tu regardes
ce film n'a rien pour toi tu as tu envie
d'aligner une série sur des grands mères
c'est pas bon ça fera sous les 3 j'ai
détesté tony montana a après bien pire
que toi et bien alors qu'au début tu
vois que cette affection pourquoi parce
qu'il est en galère
non 6/4 fesses dans le film il monte un
truc qui monte des écoles y montrent un
truc immonde et business tu vois
beaucoup de jeunes travaillent comme
pablo escobar juive là je te dis mais
qui pense qu'à lui mon frère qui lui est
son meilleur ami comme son frère il le
tue wesh mon frère c'est quoi cet essai
des animaux ça c'est pas nous ouais
l'homme sait pas qui sont ces pas
question qu elle connaît des mecs qu'ils
ont fait toute leur vie sont plus
gentils toute la planète
[Musique]
toujours pas le prêt il est prêt à
courir prêt à faire du sport tas
d'équipements et d'un équipement sportif
permanence sur lui la preuve le
vestiaire de base de la caillera a
longtemps été 100% streetwear basket
jogging souhaite à capuche et ce n'était
pas pour faire du sport
survêtement qui normalement être un
vêtement est inoffensif vêtements de
sport ya rien de plus simple le sport
devenait une espèce d'armes de d'armes
de pour impressionner faire peur pour
dire ou de ti fraude pas ne trouve pas à
moi vous savez moi mes potes on en
survêt fais gaffe ya un paradoxe dans la
mode
quand il est question de la mode des
cités c'est qu'a toujours un rejet une
fascination
c'est à dire que les jeunes petits
bourgeois avons toujours une espèce de
jeu que j'ai un peu peur de mecs de
cités en même temps me fascine
en même temps le kit de cité il a envie
de voler des ingrédients à aux petits
bourgeois et sature été comme ça deux
mondes qui s'inspire désormais
mutuellement
8 on s'offre les services de pharrell
williams
joey starr découvre le costard booba
fait le mannequin à miami et kanye west
squattent les défilés parisiens la
caillera est devenu fashion n'oubliez
pas que c'est les filles qui décide
les mecs si un mec habillé en clown
eshop dix fois plus de meuf vous à reste
50 pelo habillé en clown qui vont
s'habiller comme lui pour choper 57 plus
demain donc c'est ce qui se passe en ce
moment les mavs sont fashion l'accès aux
moyens marque adidas
ils attachent beaucoup plus d'importance
aux différents ingrédients qui composent
leur look que peut-être un jeune mec de
centre ville qui peut tout s'offrir mais
qui finalement enfin où il n'y a pas
finalement challenge des quartiers
sensibles et le challenge quand on a un
pouvoir d'achat limité c'est d'avoir du
style sans se ruiner
alors on innove on invente et on mélange
tout tiré là je veux la voir les deux
barrettes et vous allez partir en
sucette sur les premiers à mélanger ce
qui se mélangent pas celui premier à
avoir mis des baskets avec un jean sur
les premiers à avoir mis une veste de
costard avec une casquette et après
c'est des silhouettes qu'on retrouve
dans des collections qu'on retrouve
comme ça achetable tout en un dans des
boutiques
voici donc le dress code de la rue
absorbé par l'industrie du luxe jogging
souhaite basket signée dolce gabbana
chanel prada ou lanvin
le 9-3 a débarqué avenue montaigne
quand ils s'aperçoivent qu'ils ont une
influence
culturel pourquoi ne pas créer ses
propres marques et boucler ainsi la
boucle en créant leur propre marque
c'est ce qu'on fait ça à midi et hype
deux rappeurs de bondy hommes femmes
enfants une ligne entière dessiné par
leurs soins baptisée grand banditisme et
grand banditisme c'est leur histoire
quand moi je suis sorti de prison d'une
peine pour braquage on voulait tout
positiver on était on était resté depuis
une période de l'adolescence jusqu'à la
prison dans le négatif donc on a dit bon
ben je suis fiché à la brb
quoi qu'il arrive je pourrais pas trait
à la sncf je pourrais pas travailler
pour l'état je pourrais rien faire donc
après on s'est dit qu'on va créer une
marque et on va positiver
donc maintenant le grand banditisme
c'est pas devenir braqué ta bijouterie
la poste ou des particuliers c'est venir
braquer les marques qui sont multi
milliardaire et qui nous prennent le sou
depuis qu'on est petit arrêtez de dire
n'importe quoi donner moins choquant pas
de bras pas de chocolat c'est bénin dans
des cités où un jeune sur deux est au
chômage et où les distractions sont
rares
les journées se passent souvent au pied
des tours à tchatcher entre potes
[Musique]
c'est l'école du rire version bitume car
c'est dans la rue qu'est né ce qui est
devenu un sport national
la chambre est la casse le taillage en
règle
passé un truc de jeune à la base tu vois
ce que je veux dire c'est fort
intéressant pour faire rigoler les
autoroutes aux dépens de quelqu'un et
quand c'est toi ce quelqu'un m'a foutu
puisse répondre autrement ça va toujours
des pompes fois on était là on passait
des soirées entières as valet et puis
dès qu'on voyait il notre équipe arrive
et ouais on était super content se
frotter les mains
[Rires]
[Musique]
c'est presque une obligation sur la c1
c'est un truc si tu sais pas c'est pas
gazette a répondu pas vannes et saint
paul à preuve de faiblesse à ce que je
veux dire ça ou un prof de mon voeu que
les gens soient protégés pas mal stable
tandis qu'ivan dure en général d'une
physique on avait un pote qu'on appelait
double crainte rappelle le double crâne
il y avait deux crânes de crabes ont
alors dans un monde normal tu vois le
rire méchants qui veulent dans un monde
normal sera le pauvre qu'est ce qu'il
avait énoncé phallocrate cra petit nom
il avec du rire comme ça alors ça fait
mal très vite et puis après quand tu as
tout le monde qui te vannes sur ton
crâne cherche le défaut de l'autre est
ce que tu peux pas aller taper puis l'a
pas insulté sa mère puis on n'a que ça à
faire de façon de s'en faire quoi
s'énerver demain on se revoit mais c'est
vrai que tu as deux crânes quand on
regarde comme sayad au crâne et dès
qu'ils poussent passé le rappeur s'était
fait qu'on ne trouve pas un policier ne
pouvait pas mettre son casque il avait
expliqué aucun nom mais je peux pas j'ai
dansé fall auch pas quoi fournir entre
et j'ai raconté à tout le monde
bam dossier sur tout le monde j'ai pas à
nous fait notre identité aussi quelque
part et son double crâne il s'en sort
très bien aujourd'hui il a fait quelque
chose de ça mais je crois il est passé
au dessus
je crois que c'est ça on essaye de
passer au dessus d'eux on se donne les
vannes ou même avant qu'on nous le
fassent 80 dans le monde extérieur
c'est un gamin de trappes qui a fait
rentrer cet humour dans les foyers
français il y a 20 ans d'abord sur radio
nova puis sur canal bien avant de
remplir le zénith et d'être invité chez
michel drucker a revu ses fonctions on
parlait de paris pour moi pareil ça et c
c'est loin c'est mars pour moi paris 3
mai savoir qu'à des gens qui viennent me
voir jouer sur scène et qui viennent
payer leurs billets pour venir voir un
mec comme moi sur scène cc c'est
fabuleux pour moi je suis dire on peut
même pas rigolo comme michalak police ou
bats toi les cartes et rallie sly peur
et que la france en héros du groupe avec
jamel
voilà c'est le premier un petit peu
avoir avoir misé sur le devant de la
scène cet état d'esprit et cette
efficacité
dans son sillage une nouvelle génération
de comiques de toutes les couleurs a
investi les scènes et les écrans de
france
les enfants de djamel biberonné à la
tchatche la génération stand up comedy
club
ça fait longtemps vous cette rencontre
elle a battu nice j'ai rencontré ou ici
devant le théâtre l'autre en dsk du
talent
[Applaudissements]
ici le jour même nom d'accord vous
connaissez voilà d'accord en france de
grands connaissait de la france vous
avez vous voit plus sécurité tous ces
mecs qui sont élevées à la vanne
quand tu les as au téléphone quand tu
les croiser a intérêt d'être affûtés
d'avoir l'esprit vif parce qu'il va
arriver découpe en morceaux à chaque
vanne ou quoi les rois de la vanne ont
aujourd'hui leur championnat avec de
vrais professionnels et beaucoup
d'amateurs des compétitions popularisé
par mtv et qui permettent aux meilleurs
éléments de s'affronter sur scène
l'humour sniper une arme de dérision
massive
ok on sait tous déplacés pour voir le
chef
moi même je te vois tu as parlé légal
gros les mêmes là bas ont les mêmes
cheveux poids
tu voudrais faire un film avec moi grand
con ouais bah ouais les fans de l'om
voudrait que marseille soit champion
[Applaudissements]
acapela t'es pas bon ça quand tu viens
vite traite mois de métier histoire des
noirs parce que tu vas au charbon
concubin fit au fond tu vas ne pas ce
qui leur semble tu vas lui juste pour la
soirée aucun a priori aucune averse ans
sur les sources sur les nains sur les
[ __ ] sur les noirs les arabes
moi j'ai moi j'ai affronté un renoi
chinois relève année sur les renault
avait pas toi
taïbi ou non s'est fixé comme on ferait
très plaisir bien plus de choses là tu
perds intuition boutons par exemple en
mode binaire
moi mon pote si j'avais tourné j'irais
bien être portée plein de copains mer en
bateau tout quand une baisse ça doit
persister un max pour marcher à chaque
fois donc des masses tu as toutes les
crises à l'inpi sympa c'est même pas
pâti banques les testicules
attention je sentais bien la tête en
arrière parce que j'ai peur qu'avec le
proton et si tu passes qui compte une
palais
dédicacé lamson franco achille hausse
mulcair même type déjà sa mort ben ouais
c'est vrai mais c'est la famille
politique a cherché ma visite à grisy et
personne qui regarde regarde c'est pas
grave s'ils cassent à mon propre compte
et ses sauts sofiane eux qui agissent
curtis lui c'est le bourg en bresse il
faut se montre par contre c'est quoi qui
n'ont pas assisté
c'est pourquoi pour griller des steaks
une poignée dit gaga je veux pas devant
barisis avec la viande du nord prévient
direct ne fait pas ça au moins on
acceptera la rigueur des merguez
c'est bon je vois pas déduit qu ailleurs
[Musique]